de l'autre côté du périphérique parisien
la seine-saint-denis ici 43% de la
population a moins de 30 ans une
jeunesse source d'espoir et de dynamisme
mais une jeunesse qui n'a pas les mêmes
chances qu'ailleurs on pourrait parler
la police on pourrait parler de l'école
on pourrait parler de la poste on
pourrait parler des laiteries des
tribunaux on pourrait parler de fond
voilà tout est caché des écoles en
difficulté une justice des mineurs sans
moyens les enfants du 93 ne partent pas
sur le même pied d'égalité que les
autres enfants de france et pour les
acteurs de terrain qui les suivent
il y ait urgence on ne peut plus
travailler ça des répercussions
dramatiques en fait sur la situation des
mineurs les écoles de seine seine saint
denis ne sont pas des écoles où on
apprend rien c'est mon plus grand désir
qu'on change vraiment de regard et qu'on
change de regard aussi sur ces jeunes
parce que les politiques n'ont pas
compris c'est que le rempart de la
république le seul rempart qui a protégé
en seine-saint-denis et dans nos
banlieues de la république c'est l'école
[Musique]
j'ai grandi dans ce département je suis
élu depuis 1983 ça fait 35 ans et ça
fait 35 ans que je vois les choses se
dégrader ce département se paupériser et
jamais désespère à l'automne 2010 8 les
élus 93 mettre de côté leur étiquette
politique et décide de se mobiliser
contre le manque de services publics
il s'appuie sur les conclusions d'un
rapport parlementaire paru quelques mois
plus tôt cette initiative des
parlementaires avec le rapport qui a été
réalisé rédigé par deux parlementaires
l'un de la majorité en marche l'autre de
l'opposition des républicains aucun des
deux n'est en tissu de notre territoire
finalement alerte sur ce que nous disons
nous élus de seine-saint-denis depuis
des années l'état en seine-saint-denis
n'assume pas la responsabilité qui est
la sienne dans des grandes missions
l'éducation la police la justice après
avoir rencontré le premier ministre fin
septembre 2018
députés et sénateurs organise ce jour là
à bobigny une rencontre avec les maires
du 93 c'est plein
certaines remises bien et qui nous est
intolérable
ils veulent un plan d'urgence qui
règlerait définitivement les problèmes
de ce département
car si depuis le début des années 90 la
seine saint denis à tester tous les
dispositifs prioritaires existants rien
ne bouge
le 93 continuent de cumuler les
difficultés économiques et sociales dans
le département un habitant sur trois vit
au dessous du seuil de pauvreté
le double de la moyenne française il bat
également les records de chômage avec le
taux le plus élevé d'île de france
nous avons je crois les uns et des
autres à porter un constat est d
apporter une exigence commune et le
premier ministre n'a pas aidé annonce
mais il a dit nous apprendre en
attendant des moyens supplémentaires les
habitants du 93 se mobilisent comme dans
ce collège où les parents lutte contre
l'absentéisme des professeurs
le prof de techno est arrivé il était
une fois quant à lui de soirée c'est
quand on corrigeait que je dis et tu
l'as eu la semaine dernière
ça fait quand même depuis la rentrée
qu'il a eu comme une fois c'est quoi le
prochain qu il n'a rien de la faim a
écrit une série 1 4 coups de quoi
rentrer des jetons un peu déçu parce que
quand même la technologie c'est quelque
chose d'important
je sais qu'il ya des enfants de 3e
enfin on peut dire adolescents qu'ils
ont brevet cette année tu vas avoir du
mal et du retard par rapport à d'autres
je pense et je pense ça et surtout on a
des classes l'an passé qui sont restés
trois mois sans prof de français sans
prof d'anglais et c'est quoi donc c'est
pas c'est pas et cette année le
phénomène est encore relativement
marginale mais l'idée c'est
effectivement d'en finir avec cette
situation où c'est au fond les parents
et les enfants qui sont les victimes qui
doivent prendre en charge les problèmes
dont ils sont eux mêmes les victimes
quoi un moment donné il va falloir
renverser la spirale et remettent les
choses un petit peu à l'endroit quoi moi
je vous cache pas je fais partie des
classes moyennes dans le 93 on est de
moins en moins nombreux je fais partie
de ces gens qui croient encore à
l'éducation nationale publique voilà qui
considère que effectivement
mes enfants je l'aimé à l'école publique
parce que c'est aussi le lieu de la
mixité sociale
mais aujourd'hui on a vraiment
l'impression qu'en fait cette école là
il ya des gens qui veulent en finir avec
et qui font tout pour la casser quoi
[Musique]
e mail
aujourd'hui en fait on est présent avec
l'association des parents d'élèves du
collège courbet on met une
une double campagne dont une qui porte
sur
la campagne de recours en indemnisation
pour les heures perdues c'est à dire que
quand des enseignants n'ont pas été
nommés dans les établissements et qui
sont pas remplacés eh bien on engage un
recours contre l'état pour demander à ce
que nos enfants soient indemnisés à
hauteur de 1 euro par jour où ils n'ont
pas eu d'enseignants bonjour enchanté
vous êtes sénateur d'allier c'est ça là
vous avez le bulletin d'une classe de 4e
avec les disciplines donc enseignements
de techno il n'y a pas de notes
enseignement éducation musicale
il n'y a pas de note et ça ça va rester
sur le bulletin scolaire des gamins
parce que c'est dans leur dossier
scolaire quoi et là ils vont traîner ça
pendant toute la scolarité d'accord et
le problème est le suivant c'est que là
la classe que je vous montre par exemple
c'est une des meilleures classes de
courbet d'accord donc ça veut dire que
même si nos gamins y travaillent
même quand on a des bonnes classes ils
sont pénalisés parce que effectivement
pendant un trimestre ils n'ont pas eu
d'enseignement quoi et c'est là qu'elle
est la discrimination sur le papier
qu'on a les enseignants dans la réalité
les heures ne sont pas dispo scène et on
est dans un département où les gamins on
va avoir besoin que la scolarité soient
absolument suivi et ce à peu près tout
cas je pense qu'il nous faudra ici un
vivier de professeurs qui servent
effectivement en cas d'urgence à
remplacer ceux qui ne sont pas
disponibles
et aujourd'hui ça ça n'existe pas et
c'est très pénalisant pour les gamins
[Musique]
et donc là j'ai des chiffres donc je
vous parlais tout à l'heure
donc en fait quand on regarde la
proportion des néo-titulaires affectés
dans le second degré en seine saint
denis
64 % en 7 5 me contre une moyenne en
france notre but est de 21% seulement
depuis quelques années on a cherché à
répondre à ce problème extrêmement grave
d'une incapacité à assurer la continuité
de l'enseignement
on a répondu à ce problème par un
recrutement massif des contractuels ce
sont des gens qui ont le projet de
devenir enseignant mais qui ont raté un
concours en seine saint denis les
besoins sont tels en matière de
contractuels que cet effectif de deux
candidats au concours est insuffisant
pour répondre au volume nécessaire de
contractuels et donc on est obligé de
recruter des personnes qui n'ont pas le
projet professionnel de devenir
enseignants qui n'ont pas du tout
l'intention de passer le concours et qui
font ce travail comme un job passager
avant de développer leur projet
professionnel dans un autre secteur
beaucoup d'enseignants qui arrive en
seine saint denis pour des raisons qui
sont liées au hasard du recrutement si
je peux dire découvre en définitive un
contexte enseignements qui leur plaît
beaucoup et qui fait qu'ils ont envie
d'y rester
l'objectif d'aujourd'hui c'est d'écrire
un sketch et un sketch satirique
première étape définir quand même choqué
une satire d'accord qu'est ce qui se
passe quand le blanchiment jeu le
sandwich est ce que vous avez dernier
l'a alors en langage puis soutenu voilà
au début quand on m'a dit
evariste-galois sevran et surtout sevran
quand on tape sevran sur google j'ai eu
peur mais ça c'était au début bien qu'en
venant en rencontrant l'administration
quand j'ai vu monsieur m'hamdi et à
l'époque son adjoint était monsieur
d'orgères j'ai rencontré aussi l'équipe
et là j'ai compris tout de suite qui
avait un esprit plus que de camaraderie
je dirais carrément un vrai esprit de
famille presque
et là je me suis dit c'est bon c'est jeu
j'étais la plus heureuse je me suis
pincé en me disant mais c'est bon ça va
être super allez vous avez des vêtements
3 2 1 et la russie est le pays au monde
où le verbe en emmener à la deuxième
personne du singulier au présent de
l'agitation
alors tu emmènes avec l orthographe
c'est vrai que avec eux
c'est la première fois que j'ai pris
conscience que j'étais une française de
peau blanche et ça m'a un peu surprise
parce que je me suis dit mais c'est la
première fois que je suis confronté à ça
quand j'ai demandé aux élèves de se
présenter
ils ont mis en avant leurs origines et
c'était là oui je suis marocain oui je
suis algérien oui et en fait je me suis
beaucoup questionné par rapport par
rapport à eux
finalement et par rapport à leurs codes
à eux et leurs codes langagiers aussi
parce que j'avais pas du tout du tout
les codes et puis moi je suis arrivé
avec mon petit tailleur mon langage
soutenu universitaire qui passe très
bien au lycée mais ici les élèves se
sont dit aulas en compte mais ma table
on comprend pas un mot sur trois de ce
que vous racontez ça n'importe quoi pado
comment les élèves ici ils vont tester
dans mes limites c'est vraiment les
limites des limites ins et voilà mais
étant donné que j'étais bien soutenus
par l'équipe j'ai réussi à restaurer un
dialogue avec mes élèves
allez on y va calmement
bonjour bonjour je vous propose
d'équilibrer un peu un peu par monsieur
mettez-vous pas on va commencer par un
tour de table où chaque professeur
présentera un bilan rapide de l'ambiance
de classe l'ambiance de travail
alors madame crêtets en anglais
trimestre assez satisfaisant pour la
plupart des élèves s'est trouvé une
place ont un bon niveau avec de bonnes
têtes de classe en français tout d'abord
c'est une très bonne place qui a eu de
moins en moins tendance au bavardage
il a trois élèves ou deux et la partie
d'amateurs et qui dérange un petit peu
la casse
moi je suis très content parce que cette
classe et une classe dynamique où il ya
une très très belle ambiance et en même
temps une classe où on a investi et je
pense que l'investissement qu'on a mis
en place à porte ses fruits
les néo-titulaires arrive chez nous
reste chez nous trois quatre cinq années
puis après ils demandent ce qui légitime
une mutation vers leur académie
d'origine sauf que nous quand ils
arrivent en les formes
il développe de compétences chez nous il
progresse et au bout de 5 6 ans et c'est
là où ils sont au top de leur désir de
leur activité professionnelle buy-in
mythe pour aller ailleurs et donc ça
c'est une réelle difficulté pour nous
difficile même si ce proviseur bénéficie
de moyens supplémentaires dans son
collège labellisé réseau d'éducation
prioritaire renforcer rêve plus les
professeurs sont mieux payés 300 euros
par mois et ont deux heures de plus pour
travailler en équipe
pourquoi il ya eu ray plus pourquoi il
ya cette prime pourquoi ces avantages
c'est pour stabiliser les équipes
pédagogiques en stabilisant les équipes
pédagogiques on arrive à stabiliser les
projets on arriva à développer des
compétences et bénéficier du
développement de compétences
[Musique]
si certains îlots de réussite existe en
seine-saint-denis grâce à ses
professeurs ou ses chefs d'établissement
engagés ils restent des exceptions
[Musique]
ans
mi novembre 2018 les parlementaires du
93 se sont de nouveau donné rendez vous
philippe dallier vice-président du sénat
va les retrouver à l'assemblée nationale
on va évoquer cette période de cette
période d'attenté puis peut-être se
fixer une date maximale et puis voir ce
qu'on fera après voilà mais je veux
faire confiance au premier ministre
j'attends qu'ils reviennent vers nous
[Musique]
donc on avait créé mais aussi de tous
les voir comme ça dans ce format là
c'est la crise et à prendre une
initiative à l'été nerfs pour l'instant
débutants qu'aux deux côtés on peut pas
tous y arriver avec des
contre-propositions
on a perdu chez eux en médias en
attendant une réponse du gouvernement
tous veulent maintenir la pression et
décide d'organiser des rencontres avec
les syndicats
justement ce jour là devant l'assemblée
nationale valérie grimaud la
représentante des avocats de
seine-saint-denis manifeste philippe
dallier nous propose de participer à ces
rencontres vient de faire un peu le
point on va vous proposer police justice
éducation d'assister à une réunion de
travail est ce qu'on voudrait de notre
côté avant que le gouvernement ne fasse
des propositions ce qu'on espère essayez
de chiffrer les besoins demandé à
rencontrer le président du tribunal et
voitures heures mais également vous
essayez de faire le point sur les
besoins les plus criants pour nous
remettre à niveau
[Musique]
nous retrouvons valérie grimaud au
palais de justice de bobigny elle a
rendez vous avec la sénatrice communiste
eliane assassi avait de vous voir on a
totalement laissé ce d'écouter tout le
système qui accompagne la mission du
juge tout le système éducatif qui est
prioritaire en france mais qui n'a plus
les moyens de faire face
les mesures sont mises en oeuvre un an
18 mois seraient parfois pour certaines
familles des dossiers en attente des
locaux vétustes est sous-dimensionné des
postes non pourvus
le personnel du tribunal n'arrive plus à
suivre
il ya une urgence mais elle est entre
guillemets très relative cette urgence
elle existe déjà depuis plusieurs années
sauf que on arrivait encore à peu près à
faire face aux flux et aujourd'hui on
n'y arrive plus ça ça moi je suis très
inquiète pour l'avenir de notre pays en
de façon générale et particulièrement de
la seine-saint-denis vraiment moi je je
les ai vus se déliter six dernières
années parce qu'on parle de la justice
ne pourrait parler la police on pourrait
parler de l'école on pourrait parler de
la poste on pourrait parler des litres
et des tribunaux on pourrait parler de
fond voilà tout est cassé
tout est cassé
[Musique]
deux semaines
ma
mais à bobigny les plus inquiets sont
les juges pour enfants
face à une situation de plus en plus
dégradées ils ont lancé début 2010 8 un
appel au secours dans la presse marion
potier fait partie des 15 magistrats
signataires ce jour là elle fait le
point avec sa greffière
nous ferons une date pour lui parce
qu'il attend qu il dit et donc il a
débarqué au papier il a ça il est passé
il a été mis à l'abri mais du coup
tandis qu'il était majeur dont il
détient 22 octobre il est dehors et il a
les preuves comme papier il a juste un
acte de naissance n'y a pas de mention
de jugement supplétif
c'est connu un juge sans greffier ne
sert à rien et donc effectivement
normalement les greffiers sont censés
assister à l'ensemble des audiences y
comprises dans assistance éducative est
actuellement à bobigny blé greffier
n'assiste pas aux audiences d'assistance
éducative puisque ils ont un certain
nombre de tâches à accomplir et ils
n'ont pas matériellement le temps
d'assister à ces audiences
mais le pire pour marion potier ce sont
les délais de traitement
la plupart des mesures éducatif qu'elle
prend pour aider des enfants sont en
attente faute de moyens en seine saint
denis plus de 900 familles sont
concernées
on ordonne des mesures qui ne seront
pris en charge
que dans le meilleur des cas un an plus
tard or un an dans la vie d'un enfant
puisque en parle d'enfants ici de
famille c'est absolument énorme il peut
se passer énormément de choses en un an
et on s'aperçoit bien souvent que
malheureusement ce délais d'attentes
provoque a des conséquences pour les
familles par exemple parce que les
difficultés n'ont pas été traités et
l'intervention éducative n'a pas pu
avoir lieu en temps utile et la
situation s'est tellement dégradée qu'à
un moment on en vient à devoir enlever
cet enfant de ce milieu familial qui qui
le met en difficulté oui bonjour madame
sera je suis éducatrice à la veille à
bobigny dans le département de la seine
saint denis
je recherche actuellement un lieu de vie
pour un jeune garçon de 17 ans je
voulais savoir si vous aviez oui vous
avez que des filles m bon d'accord très
bien bon bah c'est notés suivant merci
emilie prat et éducatrice elle met en
application les mesures décidées par le
juge
il ya eu seize mois d'attentes avant que
l'on prenne cette mesure en charge et ce
qui fait que pendant cette attente
finalement ce jeune a continué à
commettre des actes délictueux et a du
coup en parallèle été reçu par le juge
des enfants
du coup pour cet aspect là et du coup il
ya une mesure éducative au pénal qui a
été ordonnée en parallèle voilà le jeune
non c'est pas prévu je dois faire le
point avec les ducs pjj ce matin à voile
a par contre ça serait bien que tu me le
disent après tu vois c'est dire qu'on
grimpe louer ce qu'on demandait ce qu'il
a vu
il a une synthèse la lundi on entend la
détresse des gens qui nous disent mais
ça sert à rien si lui si vous intervenez
dans deux ans ça ne sert à rien moi j'ai
aussi beaucoup de familles quand on
commence l'intervention qui nous disent
non mais aujourd'hui ça va beaucoup
mieux c'était il ya un an et demi qu'on
avait besoin de vous mais vous n'étiez
pas là donc c'est vrai qu'ils savent que
ben c'est pas nous personnellement qui
sommes responsables
mais on est quand même en première ligne
pour recevoir ça et c'est vrai que pour
nous c'est surtout est une immense perte
de sens parce que je suis en train de
ce que je suis en train de faire c'est
justement de distribuer des mesures à
puisqu'il s'est en fait on gère à la
fois les aides éducatives en milieu
ouvert et les mesures judiciaires
investigations il ya par exemple une
mineure avec qui a fait plusieurs ts
il faut absolument pouvoir la suivre
je regarde dans ma liste de mesures en
attente elle arrive à la 135e place ça
veut dire que je peux pas distribuer la
mesure avant je sais pas combien de
temps donc par exemple cette jeune je
vais rappeler les partenaires je vais
voir un peu évaluées et je vais la
mettre en priorité mais quand je les
mets en priorité elle risque de prendre
la place d'une autre priorité en fait on
est toujours dans une histoire de
priorité
on n'est plus dans un problème d'éthique
on est dans un problème de morale à quoi
bon jour scheider et toi c'était oui on
va aller s'installer dans la salle va
pas bien emilie prat a rendez vous avec
scheid à elle la suit depuis cinq ans ce
jour là elles font le point sur son
parcours au début pour moi c'était
important après ses distances
c'était après j'ai bienvenus elle se
laisse ou plus vous allez trouver pour
moi que tout c'est avec ma mère vous
n'avez pas trouvé c'est souvent est-ce
que tu penses que s'il n'y avait pas eu
d'intervention d'un éducateur auprès de
toi ton serait au même point aujourd'hui
ce que tu as une idée un peu de ça est
ce que tu te pose cette question des
fois oui des fois je chie dessus
au début c'était compliqué pour moi
parce qu'il fallait que j'apprenne à lui
faire confiance
d après on a fait des sorties tous d'en
parler de tout et de rien il ya des
moments où j'ai su lui faire confiance
parce que j'avais besoin en matière d
après ce parti tout seul au film quand
on a la chance d'avoir un suivi comme
celui çi d'un c'est une satisfaction
vient se dire ben oui ce travail de
fourmi
finalement il a
oui il a un grand intérêt il a des
conséquences qui sont super favorable
c'est une jeune voilà qui a su faire
confiance et pour le coup qui a vraiment
été à l écoute d'elle-même et qui a eu
beaucoup besoin qu'on la valorise mais
qui aujourd'hui voilà son fort très très
bien et je suis très très contente très
contente pour elle est très fier d'elle
parce que c'est vrai qu'elle a elle a
été très courageuse dans quelques mois
shahid a va commencer une formation en
pâtisserie
mais d'autres n'ont pas eu sa chance
comme les jeunes adolescents placés dans
ce centre d'accueil à saint denis après
un parcours chaotique
bonjour c'est ce jour là il y en a ça si
bien voir comment fonctionne la
structure qui vous êtes là tous les
jours où nous est d'accord on déplace
aussi d'accord santé mais apparaît plus
sexy que dans un collège parce que si
j'arrive à m'adapter au frais dans un
collège pas la même chose s'est entouré
de jeunes ont construit à partir ya
plusieurs pertes de perturbateurs et tu
peux me contenter mettre dans un tour de
l'arrivée s'il ya des sénateurs ça
faisait déjà un moment ça va lui faire
part bientôt plus étonné de la voir chez
jallet avant 14 pas callac g10 est hélas
alors maintenant tu veux te quitter la
tunisie des jets
signer mon contrat civique j'avais
entraîné en alsace très pas entraîner
quoi une équipe de basket barreaux c'est
ce que tu voulais faire au début
au début je n'avais pas de projets ouais
après ça arrivait donc lui se passe
comme ça que j'aime bien moi qui ai rien
n'est fait longtemps la grèce elle veut
gagner
basket est gay et les doigts mais aussi
je ne pensais pas qu'on pouvait avoir un
autre temps vous demandez aux éducateurs
sont pouvez demander du temps avec eux
pour comparer ce prime
et je trouve ça déjà bien et sont là
pour nous pour notre avenir et moi ça me
touche vraiment parce que je me dis que
c'est ma dernière chance et que j'ai le
choix et qu'il faut que je réussisse
je sais que j'ai pas eu à ma place dans
les collèges dans les lycées et que ma
place est ici et voilà ici je travaille
je me mets jeune julia et je me donne à
fond pour réussir la laisser des
commandes pour le directeur norbert
giuliani son centre d'accueil pour
mineurs est la dernière roue du carrosse
d'une protection de l'enfance qui
fonctionne mal
faute de moyens on accueille des jeunes
qui à un moment donné
aurait dû être accueilli dans un
établissement médico-social et qui ont
un handicap qui n'a pas été détecté
on accueille des jeunes dont les parents
et la souffrance des parents n'a pas été
prise en compte des jeunes qui ont un
parcours vraiment très chaotique qui
vont avoir des prises en charges
multiples avec un placement pendant un
an un endroit deux ans et 6,2 or ici on
voit bien qu'il ya me donner quelque
chose qui peut pas se mettre en place au
niveau des institutions ici pour le
suivi de la famille il ya un manque de
cohérence dans le parcours
d'accompagnement de ces faits mais je me
suis toujours battu pour l'égalité et
pour le respect de la personne humaine
et pour des droits aussi et donc
effectivement je continuerai
malheureusement je pourrais lire
malheureusement à me battre pour que
effective les enfants qui sont
effectivement les adultes de demain
puissent grandir dans une société en
étant et padoue oui alors il faut des
moyens
oui il faut des moyens mais aujourd'hui
ce n'est pas le choix qu'ont fait nos
gouvernants pas ceux d'aujourd'hui
mais ceux d'hier et ceux d'avant-hier et
donc on est en train de constater
quelque chose qu'on aurait pu empêcher
il y a quelques années si on avait fait
de l'individu l'individu le point
cardinal des choix politiques
or ce n'a pas été le cas
[Musique]
et il y en a c'est si comme philippe
dallier ont grandi dans ces quartiers
difficiles
ils sont sortis s'ils n'ont pas les
mêmes opinions politiques
leurs parcours personnels les unis dans
un même combat donné à chahid arim sian
kelly et tous les enfants de la seine
saint denis les mêmes chances que et les
mêmes chances que les autres enfants de
france
[Musique]